were you on tour with louis capaldi
right before kind of everything shut
down
yes yes i was what was that like because
he's a bit of a he's a bit of a
character huh
yeah it was great we didn't spend that
much time together um because the tour
was pretty big and you know we are all
on separate buses and stuff so um
but the tour was was nice um
it was it was really cool uh to get up
in front of you know his audience and to
perform my songs and also to find that
like a lot of the people in the crowd
knew my music that was exciting
um cool yeah yeah it was great the the
it was crazy at the end because we had
to come home and end the tour
early because of coronavirus so yeah
that was kind of wild
but then there's that did you text him
on tour
i did i did i did i said hi and i go on
tour with you and he said
he said no and i said really and he said
yeah and i said
okay and then i showed up with at his
house with um
with a uh uh uh roses
and a glazed ham i don't know why glazed
ham came to my mind but it did
and uh and then he was like all right
you can keep the ham but i'll take the
roses
and that's how we ended up going tour
together
i feel like that was your initiation and
you made it you impressed him
yeah exactly after that it was like game
over
that's awesome he gave me a big kiss on
the lips and that was it
and that was it i saw on your instagram
that you were able to write some music
with casey musgraves
and i can imagine what a big deal that
was i mean she's loved by so many people
but for you
she's a bit of an idol so what was that
experience like
yeah it was cool um
it was cool but we wrote a song about
getting sick um before all this stuff
happened so i don't think this song is
ever going to come out i think it would
be in poor taste
it's not not like it just doesn't fit
the times now
so that unfortunately didn't work out
but it is what it is i at least got the
experience of making music with somebody
that i really admire
yeah well and now you also have that
kind of open door you have that
connection you guys have worked together
did you hear that my mouth just squealed
no
it was like i missed it why because was
it just like a weird
it just it just happened i didn't burp
it just happened
oh i thought that's what happens when
you talk about casey master cribs i
wasn't sure
yes i get so excited
um you know how they say never meet your
idols um yeah you know because
you can be a little disappointed but was
she cool because she seems cool
she was very cool yeah i have a song
about that
it's called death of a hero oh cool and
because i met mine one time
and then it wasn't what i thought but
then but then that song introduced me
to my actual hero and he ended up being
everything i thought he was going to be
and more so
irony is is that heroes do still exist
so i'll have to write a part two to that
song
okay i like that i like that yeah um
okay and one other thing i do want to
ask you um is it true that you learned
how to play the guitar
to impress a girl uh
yeah but it didn't work but
no i just sorry i had something in my
mouth i don't know what it was
um but yeah it was cool uh she didn't
care
so but it doesn't matter because like
it's nice sometimes you need like uh
sometimes you need like an external
variable that motivates you to
achieve something and uh i feel like
it was uh it was a catalyst
that uh i don't know i'm trying to say
she was cute she didn't like me it broke
my heart
or a song about it and that's it but
now look where you're at so so has that
helped you in your future
future with with the ladies
i mean i don't really know i live in my
parents house so i can't
i'm not really sure uh and and right now
you can't even go outside to see anybody
so
like i don't yeah it's not really like
the number one thing on my mind right
now
uh i hear that i'm in my parents house
right now they don't have ac
so life is just oh is it wait is it hot
it is it's kind of muggy hot for the
past couple of days so it's just like
good times here you know
ah i understand yeah i'm from arizona so
i know how i can get hot yeah um you
have such a big following on social
media and there's all this buzz about
you online do you pay attention to that
like do you feel the pressure at all or
is it just kind of fun
um i think the fun part is that
um you know when you look at a number
like whatever you know however many
followers you have or people like your
photo whatever like each one of those
likes is an individual human being who's
been touched by something that you made
which is really exciting whether whether
they whether it's like in a good way or
they maybe they hate what you do but
either way it like made them feel
something which is
is cool um
but i think that's what's cool about it
but i think that
it can be very addicting
and it was i was built in such a way to
do that so it can sometimes be toxic
um yeah there's negatives and positives
yeah do you ever have to take breaks
from social media do you ever feel like
yeah all the time
yeah yeah well i don't do it naturally
you know my friends had to make me a
facebook like
like right before we went to college
they were like dude we're not gonna be
able to talk to you like if you don't
have social media
but i didn't like i had a myspace that i
never used and then my friend's like oh
you have to make facebook and
i don't really update it or anything
like that like my personal one but it's
yeah
social media is a very unnatural thing
for me it's like i don't really like to
share
what i do like through text or photos i
like to share it through music
that's the most natural part for me yeah
so what's next for you then
i'm probably gonna eat a sandwich in a
minute